the sun has like this seven year cycle
or 14-year cycle depending on how you
want to look at it
and it gets active and it gets inactive
and when it gets active
it it puts out a lot more radiation at
certain wavelengths and they don't
matter so much to us down here
hard to detect on the surface of the
earth but in the very upper atmosphere
solar activity particularly solar flares
those solar
excursions
make big changes in the extreme upper
atmospheric density they can change the
temperature of the upper atmosphere and
hence the density like they puff up the
atmosphere of the earth and it gets way
denser
at like
two three four five hundred kilometers
even
above the surface of the earth when the
sun gets active and that makes stuff get
dragged down much faster because if
there's more atmospheric density it gets
slowed down and then it slows down more
and then it gets denser the lower
atmosphere and it burns up this is the
solar cycle and the debris re-entries
kind of super posed with each other so
when the sun is active the red curve
more debris re-enters so that's you know
there's some cleaning that's going on
naturally but but not enough
so
another thing we
do is we restrict the lifetime of
satellites
and meaning so we don't want a bunch of
dead satellites up there there are
already too many and we really don't
want dead satellites up there so what
does that mean
well you can never ensure that a
satellite won't die and just remain in
orbit as a basically a big piece of junk
but what you can do is you can
say you have to dispose of it after a
certain number of years if it's still
alive so you have to have an engine on
it with enough propellant
to take it
and re-enter into the earth's atmosphere
or at the very least put it into an
orbit that nobody cares about so those
are disposal options another thing you
can do is just fly it very low to begin
with and then you know it's going to
have a very short lifetime
even if it dies
that's what we do at planet labs mostly
is we
build
satellites we launch them into
relatively low orbits they're only
designed to last say five years because
after five years the technology is
presumably much better and we don't
really want them anymore so we just have
them
at a low enough orbit that after about
five years they re-enter and burn up but
that's not always been the case if
you're building a billion dollar
satellite you might want it to last a
lot longer than five years and
therefore you you have to be very
careful and have some way to dispose of
it and unfortunately
the world's largest piece of space junk
right now is a billion dollar satellite
called nvsat that the european european
space agency sent up there it's about
the size of a school bus and it died
and it's totally dead i mean it's and
it's just
it's up there and
these very large dead objects are in a
sense the biggest threat because if
something collides with them
they can make a huge mess
there's a lot of proposals also for
going up and getting stuff out of it
that's called active debris removal
so
the first thing that you can avoid you
do to sort of avoid collisions at least
for active satellites is have a traffic
management system kind of like we do
with air traffic management and you want
you want the satellites to you want
everybody to know where all the
satellites are and you want everything
in an orderly pattern so that collisions
are very unlikely this would be a
typical
distribution of satellites in a big
constellation like maybe starlink or
oneweb or something like that i mean
this is simplified but a lot of
satellites in a lot of different orbits
and it might look like a giant mess and
how could you
ever
you know how could you hope to not have
a collision with a constellation this
dense
but the the issue is that if you look at
it in a three-dimensional geometry you
can see that there's ways to kind of
thread stuff through each other
um you can imagine
this thing sort of fully populated with
these orange dots like there could be
thousands and thousands of them up there
and if they're all choreographed just
right they can sort of do a dance and
one way to understand the dance is to
map it out in in other coordinate
systems so that you know like instead of
latitude and longitude on the earth you
can kind of map it out in these grids
and tauruses where you're using
different mathematical functions and
then they turn into these regular square
patterns and in a sense every satellite
is just sitting in a box now when you
put it back onto the three dimensions of
the sphere of the earth
it doesn't look like a box so much
anymore so here's here's the starlink
constellation and this is we're mapping
it out not in latitude and longitude or
not in altitude and inclination or any
of the standard orbital elements and
what we see here is a bunch of starlink
satellites and the ones that are in
their assigned orbits are these pale
gray dots and then this the brightly
colored ones are the ones that have been
recently launched so the ones that have
recently been launched are the ones that
are moving and once they get into their
assigned positions they turn they turn
gray
each different launch is a different
color
and you can see as they get gray they
just drop onto this grid
and this this means that even though
they're always orbit around the earth in
this complicated dance in their in this
special coordinate system they're just
lying on a grid
the diamond shaped ones are defunct some
of those defunct ones
they're really defunct like they have no
control over them anymore
um but the point is that you can see
these gray ones on the right slowing
down and now they're locked into their
position and now we're going to watch
these blue
ones they slow down and they lock into
their position and turn gray and you can
see that they're slowly building up this
grid and and then when you have this
grid if everybody stays in their box
once it's just a rigid grid and they're
all up there and everybody stays in
their little box there's not going to be
any collisions in that constellation and
so we could have boxes like that
globally you know for the entire world
satellites actually and we can have lots
of satellites up there if everybody
stays in their box
and um of course this is complicated by
the fact that you've got debris objects
streaming through here who don't know
about the boxes right
but
it's a start
so what do we do about these debris
objects so we can do active debris
removal
you know everybody's got their favorite
idea or we're going to build with the
robot with claws and it's going to grab
stuff and then bring it back to earth or
we're gonna like this is an actual uh an
actual
satellite servicing mission but
satellite servicing and debris removal
are very similar you have to get into
proximity of another satellite you have
to
grab grab it you have to attach to it
and then you have to do something either
refuel it or bring it
or bring it back to the atmosphere so it
can burn up or move it to some graveyard
orbit but this is very similar to what
you'd have to do
if you were trying to bring a dead
satellite back
now
the problem is oftentimes debris objects
and dead objects they're tumbling
makes it harder to get get a hold of
them so
of course people have said oh well we'll
just inflate like giant balloons and you
know we'll like will like
somehow stick it to a balloon or or may
or everyone thinks they're very clever
why don't you just send up a net and the
thing to remember about this is
these are objects in orbit and if you do
this if you get something wrong you end
up just creating more debris like you
can imagine this net gets tangled up and
then you know now you've got an even
worse problem right and now you've got
an even bigger thing flying around there
or something accidentally
it gets tangled up and it hits something
else i mean these and also by the way
all these kind of schemes like this they
also are like set anti-satellite weapons
in disguise because i could just as well
use this to go take your satellite and
and and remove it or to cover it up or
turn it off as i could to get out of
take a piece of space junk out of orbit
i don't know where people come up with
these ideas but
i just collected as many as i could
uh you know we're going to catch it with
harpoons
and then drag it away
now this is actually this is a this was
a european space mission that got pretty
far along the planning phase called e.d
orbit this thing on the right is that
school bus sized
gigantic envy sat dead
environmental satellite and then the
thing on the left was going it was fully
all designed and ready to go well it
wasn't built yet and it was going to
grab the envy sat which was not tumbling
i don't believe and attach itself to the
envy set and then just de-boost the
whole thing down into the atmosphere and
that got cancelled unfortunately so
that's envy set is still up there
but they are actually launched this is
going to launch in 2025. this is called
clear space the thing on the left is
getting this
medium-sized piece of junk that's known
to be up there and um
uh you're spending 86 million euros on
this mission to bring back this one
piece of junk
[Music]
you